liebe Freunde des gepflegten
Ausbildungsberufes ja heute ein bisschen
anders bei klickum ich bin an um im früh
zu Köln denn die IHK die Industrie und
Handelskammer hier lädt euch zu einem
außergewöhnlichen Event ein dem A2B
Speed Dating da sollt ihr angeblich in
10 Minuten zum Beruf kommen aktuelles
Datum Link und so weiter unten im
Infotext deshalb stelle ich euch jetzt
den Beruf des Brauers vor und das ist
ein außergewöhnliches Video indem ich
unter anderem mich an Fässern
bierfessssern abarbeite euch zeig warum
alles Käse in Brauhäusern sein kann und
auch ein wenig angepisst bin so wie viel
Flaschen sind jetzt hier hier laufen
jetzt ungefähr 45000 Flaschen ü Wand die
Stunde wenn die Maschine komplett
ausgelöet ist Wahnsinn und ich sag mal
so beherrschst du das jetzt würdest du
das Ding alleine in Gang Kriegen in Gang
kriegen würde es schon ja ob ich alle
Störungen beseitigen könnte weiß ich
nicht aber Großen und Ganzen soll behbar
sein Okay Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn okay wo ist den wo wo wo wo wo
okay okay
okay was ist das hier ach ein Kasten
sensationell meine Damen das lernt man
natürlich auch in der Ausbildung zum
Bierbrauer wie mache ich aus einem
Blechfass eine
Werkzeugkiste das ist das Gesellenstück
von
oh was ist das oh oh moment das müssen
wir auch mal
gucken
oh
oh oh
durstlöcher ja da braucht man keine
Angst haben dass die Party ne geht nee
hier verdurst man nicht
unglaublich es geht da hinten noch
weiter haben wir noch ganze
fasshallen als wird soll wir ja nichts
trinken wie hältst du selber mit dem
Alkohol ja ich trinke wir do schon mal
ganz gern Gold oder zwei ja gut okay
aber in Maßen genau weil sonst kann man
sich am nächsten Morgen nicht mehr
konzentrieren das ist ja unglaublich
diese
Menge
wusst gar nicht dass es so viel Kölsch
gibt ja nur bei uns so alles
unglaublich da steht dran
31.121 das
heißt bis dahin haltbar ja das wird halt
so verkauft welch zuerst produziert
wurde ja alkoholfrei ist länger haltbar
das ein Jahr
haltbar meine Damen und Herren
jahrgangsbier der gute ELER das ist ja
noch mehr Bier na ist alles leer gut ach
das ist leer gut okay da bin ich ja
beruhigt ein kleiner Größenvergleich mal
ihr kennt alle
Gabelstapler ich stell mich jetzt mal
gleich daneben nur mal so um zu sehen
wie groß so ein gabelstaler hier
ist so sind so groß sind die gabelstaler
hier dann können Sie das zu mir nach
Hause
liefern ich habe eine Party am
Wochenende ist genau die richtige Menge
ja ja genau danke
Ciao Wochenende ist
jettet dann haben wir hier unseren
malzturm da sind sechs Silos drin ja da
ja lagern die unsere Malze Malze
vermelzte Gerste Gerste ne also das
heißt Gerste die wurde gekeimt und dann
in dem Moment wo sie gekeimt wird wird
sie getrocknet ja sie wird dann nachher
noch getrocknetau dass es lagerfähig
wird und ja dann wird drin genau können
wir auch mal reingehen ja ja okay da
gucken wir mal das weil das ist ja das
Basisprodukt vom Bier ohne das gibt's
kein Bier genau Hopfen brauchen wir
nicht unbedingt aber Hopfen brauchen wir
auch aber ohne mals geht n aber es ging
auch theoretisch ohne Hopfen wird nicht
schmecken wahrscheinlich aber hätten
Bier mit Z mit Alkohol und Kohlensäure
aber der Geschmack wä nicht so wä nicht
optimal also ohne eben gekeimte Gerste
geht nicht hier sieht man
jetzt genau so ist das schon gekeimt nee
doch doch doch das komm bekommen wir von
der melzerei alles und das gekeimte
woran erkennt man das weil da ist jetzt
nicht nur eine Sprosse die da rauskommt
nee nee die werden no alle abgetrennt
das schme Z die werden abgeschnitt oder
abge keine Ahnung abgedingst abgedingst
abgedingsen abgedroschen gibt doch ein
facht ab also so sieht es aus das ist
die Basis des
Bieres kannst auch mal probieren ja
relativ süß
UPS
hey kann
essen aber das das schmeckt so wie es im
Brauhaus riecht so ein bisschen genau
und das ist nicht immer angenehm weil
früher als das früh noch in der
Innenstadt war da bin ich da ab und so
vorbeig gefahren und immer wann riecht
am schlimmsten schlimm das R
gutan riecht am besten am besten ja
immer wenn wir brauen oben im also im
Brauprozess selber das was daau weil es
wird ja erhitzt auf vi viel Grad genau
ja verschiedene Stufen erst so auf 60
70° und später wird auch noch gekocht ja
und dann das ein riesen Kessel der kocht
da gucken mal gleich mal den Kessel an
und das riecht dann sehr gut wie ich
gehört habe ja sehr gut
Geschmackssache geh
hopfenlager
hier ist es jetzt relativ kalt drin bin
falsch gekleidet muss ich sagen das ist
ja eisig kalt ja unser Hopfen muss halt
gekühlt werden damit er nicht seiner
Kraft
verliert hier so jetzt kommen wir zum
Hopfen diesen
Folien jetzt ein
bitteropfen noch bitterer als die
anderen so soll ich jetzt nicht essen
unglaublich bitter hey das wäre was für
Elton vs Simon wie viel Hopfen könnt ihr
Essen der
schck dagegen ist bitter
Schokolade ein Fest der süße
boah das ist so dermaßen bitter hast du
das schon mal gemacht ja dummerweise
dummerweise macht man nicht zweimal auch
ein bisschen scharf ne ja brennt ne
kratzt kratzt
kratzt nee so ja das sieht ja mal echt
aus wie der Brauerei ja genau das
Herzstück unser Brauerei guten Tag
hier der einzige Kochtopf in dem man
klettern
kann wie so eine Küchenmaschine mit so
ein eine Rührgerät direkt drin genau D
ich alles anpappt und alles gleich
behandelt wird wir berührt das kann wie
zu Hause auch anbrennen ja genau K muss
man aufpassen okay ja hier durch dieses
Rohr kommt dann das malsschrot was in
der Mühle gemalen wurde und wird dann
hier mit Wasser vermischt mhm und dann
über verschiedene
Temperaturstufen wird dann durch Enzyme
die in den Malz enthalten sind wie auch
bei melzen entstanden sind wandelt dann
die in den Malz enthaltene Stärke zu
Zucker um und den wir nachher brauchen
zum
vergehren genau und der vergehren das
passiert dann durch Hefe genau durch
Zugabe von Hefe und die verarbeitet das
wie gesagt zu Kohlensäure und Alkohol
und
der oder das Hopfen der Hopfen der
Hopfen was macht der dann am Schluss der
kommt am Schluss rein ne genau den geben
wir hinten in den drei Gefäßen für die
drei verschiedenen hopsen sind auch
verschiedene
Zeit Zeiten zu denen wir gegeben werden
weil jeder Hopf eine andere Eigenschaft
hat und ja okay ja aber was macht er
dann mit dem gibt einmal die bittere und
noch Aroma okay also das Aroma bitter
und ich glaube auch für die Haltbarkeit
also zum früher war so die Haltbarkeit
ist auch Biss Desinfektion oder ja ja
Desinfektion nicht aber es ist es
schützt ein bisschen okay alles alles
gelernt ja genau alles hier und in der
Berufsschule haben wir das alles gelernt
ist das viel büffeln oder geht das ganz
leicht ja sag mal ist ein interessanter
Beruf deshalb also fällt eigentlich eher
leicht also man merkt sich die Sachen
eher da zur Prüfung hin wird dann
natürlich schon etwas intensiver das
Lernen und das merkt man sich so gut
dieser Beruf die ideale Verbindung von
Hobby Freizeit und Beruf ist ja genau
trinken und Trinken machen man kann das
ja glaube ich auch zu Hause machen oder
geht auch zu Hause klar nicht in den
Maßstäben aber das geht ne nur Kochtopf
brauchening auch schon kann man wirklich
von K Kochtopf bis zu einer Kleinanlage
die man kaufen kann geh alles hast das
mal gemacht ja wir brauchen in der
Schule selber Bier wir haben da auch
klein suanlage kriegen man ungefähr 50 l
immer raus okay einmal pro Block das
heißt die Parys in eurer Berufsschule
sind die besten ja kann man definitiv zu
sagen okay ich verstehe langsam warum
dieser Beruf so attraktiv ist
sensationell das ist natürlich das A und
O dass die Kölner hofbu P Josef
frühbrauerei
ein von der IHK geprüfter und damit
gemäß Berufsbildungsgesetz anerkannter
Ausbildungsbetrieb ist denn nur dann
darf mal
ausbilden also jetzt hier
irgendwo kommt hier Bier raus ich finde
das ja was unübersichtlich aber Tobias
scheint sich
auszukennen bei mir zu Hause sieht der
Zapf aber anders aus sonst kannst du
nicht Zapfen hast du nur Schaum ach okay
hey das wäre ja für manches fast immer
das
richtige na
toll
der hat aber Druck auf der
Blase ja nen isten ein
früh
schmeckt J hier in der Küche sieht man
beim frü kann man nicht nur Brauer
werden sondern auch Koch lernen bei Koch
Industrie Kaufleute werden da
ausgebildet Hotelfachleute und
restaurantfach Leute das alles kann man
hier
lernen jo alles Käse hier warum nur pass
auf jetzt gibt's eine kleine Stunde in
Köcher Kultur was ist eine halbe han gut
der informierte weiß es vielleicht schon
der uninformierte denkt es ist ein
halbes Hähnchen ist es aber nicht es ist
ein röggelchen mit Kies was ist ein
röggelchen mit Kies das ist ein Brötchen
mit Käse und zwar mit mittelaltem Gauda
so das hier ist junger Gauda und aus mit
Tradition in die Zukunft so ist nämlich
das Motto von früh das wurde früher
schon gemacht da kam der Junge Gauda an
und dann wurde er erstmal eingelagert
bis er mittelalt war so und das ist er
ich weiß gar nicht ist jetzt hier schon
ah ne guck mal hier da sieht man es neu
alt so das heißt das ist ja alles neuer
der muss jetzt noch lagern und dann wird
daraus ein richtiges rugchen mit
Kies
so achtung jetzt kommen wir ins
Zentrum hier lagert das Bier was gleich
zeige ich
noch ja in an der Schwemme gezapft wird
und jetzt hier kommt das auf den
fallsack falls ne weil sonst geht's
kaputt und jetzt pass auf Aung dieser
vorrad der da drin wir jetzt gesehen hab
der ist in zwei Tagen alle ja so ist das
hier in Köln die Leute haben Durst
Hammer
muss mich ein bisschen ansch das ist
nicht W also das muss
man ich muss trainieren okay aber aus
diesem Fass hier da kriege ich jetzt
gleich ein leckeres kühles frühkölsch
oben an der
Schwemme das wird serviert von Kürbissen
so nennt man die Kellner in Köln aber
das Besondere am Kürbiss er bedient in
einer sehr persönlichen Art und Weise
also nicht wundern wenn man da mal ein
wenig ruppig angefasst wird das gehört
dazu das ist die Attraktion hier und so
bezahlt der Kürbis also pass auf das
geht jetzt folgendermaßen der hat hier
so eine Marke dann legt ihr die hier
drauf und dann bekommt er ein Kölsch
dass er dann wieder sein Gast gibt also
hier wird ganz perfekt abgerechnet bekom
jetzt auch gleich vileich das kann sich
nur um Stunden
handeln super danke also noch mal zu
wohl so funktioniert das hier
PR